à l'été 1993 le québec tombe amoureux de
julie et de nouveaux gros les colas mike
gauthier était au lancement du premier
album des colocs en wallonie devenu le
club soda
quand j'avais vu que j'avais six de base
cpi s'était déjà fait remarquer
lorsqu'il y avait eu l empire de futures
stars je prends jamais remarqué parce
que s'il établit entre les québécois et
les colocs
c'est le coup de foudre et l'autre se
battent fraîcheur qui arrive avec
l'album puis julie qui jouait à la radio
pour ça ce procès des arrangements de
fanfare c'est très enjoué sas d'entrée
très joyeux tente le premier contact
qu'on a avec les colocs c'est la joie
malgré le fait qu'ils dénoncent beaucoup
d'injustice sociale
on est dans la set
[Musique]
le groupe détonne avec la variété pop
mielleuse qui joue à la radio québec à
l'époque et propose sont plus inspirés
du grunge nirvana qui était arrivé
rogers 91-92 tout allait vraiment de
cette grande vague de rock le
contestataire 1 qui lient d'une
génération qui voulait être entendu et
tout ça
à ce jeu
bébé est dans cet esprit là avec ses
chansons la dénonciation
donnez lui une chance faites nous une
place malgré des textes engagés
les colloques réussissent à toucher le
vaste public c'est un peu
inter-générationnelle ça aussi this n'a
pas un style musical des phillies et sa
pop the works t'as pas un style six
états comme tout le monde pouvait
apprécier ça y est endossée par
l'industrie je pense au gala de l'adisq
qui a suivi la parution de leur premier
album you tout raflé le vin merci
beaucoup à tout et qui ont travaillé sur
julie au fil des ans les membres du
groupe ont changé au fil des influences
et des sonorités que dd souhaite
intégrer le son des colloques
c'était vraiment le québécois pure laine
du lac saint jean hyper ouvert sur le
monde et sur les cultures et ça ça
représentait à québec des années 90 qui
s'ouvre est vraiment les couleurs c'est
aussi un look et une esthétique des
forfaits avaient d'ailleurs étudié le
cinéma à chaque fois qu'on recevait un
nouveau clip des colonnes c'est un bijou
c'était une super complexe léché
minutieux ça devrait toujours quelque
chose de très original
le clip pour julie soria la musique des
colocs associative est pas vous donner
avec ta l'épaule à sa cause en avant
dans une joie parrot qui contrastait
avec la réalité plus sombre de dédé
fortin
le chanteur roch qu'andré forte est mort
il à chaque a été immense quand dédé
fortin nous a quittés immense c'était un
gars extrêmement aimé
genre je pense que je pense que la
population ne se met pas à quel point
cela était était malheureux les ailes
une détresse
[Musique]
trente ans plus tard julie et les colocs
l'ont pas prise on arrive ici nabi
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]
ouattara mènent la barque